stood a lot of times that you know how I
said I'm Bon Jovi when I said and that's
that there's no change in it I'm Bon
Jovi when I said okay that's it that's
it you might as well [ __ ] cut the
sleeves off to my shirt because I'm Bon
Jovi when I said my [ __ ] my man
spread and I don't give a [ __ ] if you're
uncomfortable it chill um tease my hair
out cuz I'm Bon Jovi my knees can't get
further apart
I'm like a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay a lot of
times I'll hang my knee over a chair
I'll hang my knee over a [ __ ] what do
you call it a table I'm chillin I'm at
cafes a lot and I'm doing this this week
I was at one it'll remain nameless and
the girl comes up to me that works there
and she was like excuse me can you take
your foot off now look I get it if my
feet are on furniture not okay feet are
dirty the feet shoes they've got piss
all over them because you walk around in
toilets and bathrooms and [ __ ]
you piss and the back [ __ ] piss gets
on the [ __ ] [ __ ] and the bottom of
the thing you step and [ __ ] piss [ __ ] all
over the [ __ ] right so I get that I
never put my feet on furniture like that
okay Mike half yes my calf all right can
you take your foot off she says and I
roll my eyes at her and I say yeah sure
okay and I go like this
okay and I here's how you know I'm
pissed I go right to the group text and
I say god damn [ __ ] why do I
always dude I get so much people I get
so much [ __ ] from establishments for
doing the Bon Jovi spread and I'm just
chilling man that's that is a [ __ ]
rule that isn't should not be a rule if
you sit with your feet up it's okay
you're not gonna you can't tell me what
to do with my body dude I'm
feminists you're not gonna tell me where
to put my limbs it's not a health hazard
to put my [ __ ] calf on a table I
talked about with the group text and
like why to get so mad about this oh
it's really it's you know it says one of
the other more my other buddies is like
well I'm like you can't thumb will do my
body is like they're not they're telling
you they're telling you how to be polite
in their establishment let me tell you
something here's my rebuttal no I'm
chilling dude can I not do this can I do
this can I not do this can I not do this
can I not put my leg up can I not put my
leg up in the air like this would you
tell me to put my foot down if I had to
up an air like this would you tell me to
put it down no you wouldn't
okay well let me put it to you this way
what about if it's like that
on the other caps on the table but the
foots off the table you would wouldn't
you
you would you would have a problem if my
[ __ ] foot was on it wouldn't you
no let me ask you a question what's the
difference between that and that what's
the difference dude what's the
difference between us it's down to the
penis and well nothing I don't give a
[ __ ] I mean what's the difference
between this and this what's the
difference dude and you're gonna tell me
not to do the thing like this I should
have one like this sure yeah I won't do
it sure sure sure
there you go how's that Australian chick
because she was Australian excuse my kin
you talking things over the hybrid thing
sure yeah I can do me a favor real quick
though call yourself a kangaroo God that
made me mad yeah I'll move my limbs for
you because it's your body not mine I'm
a FEMINIST baby you don't tell me what
to do with my body
wrong one always hit the wrong one yes
I'm a FEMINIST baby I'm a [ __ ]
feminist baby dude don't tell me where
to put my calves dude I'm serious man
I'm gonna run for [ __ ] local mayor
and I'm gonna say this calf situation is
out of control
hi I'm Chris Leah's calf situations out
of control a lot of times when you're
sitting with your feet up at the Kafe if
your feet aren't even on a table or the
back of someone's chair
people will say come up to you and say
can you please put your foot down well
I'm here to make that stop I'm Krista
Leah and I'm running for [ __ ] mayor
of Lompoc and I understand that a lot of
you guys you got trying to do the Bon
Jovi sit-ins and they're not letting you
do the bun jovi sit-ins well that's not
okay on my dime that ends today
vote for me I had paid for by Chris
Aliyah cuz it's Chris D'Elia before I
hit the jeremy renner one one more time
I'm gonna [ __ ] it just it's just
don't tell me where to put my [ __ ]
limbs
Oh ma'am Oh Oh ma'am is my dick inside
you know then stop complaining
uh ma'am this is cafe right uh ma'am I'm
inside yeah
what if I did that what if she said can
you move can you ask you a few on the
table and I said oh do it ma'am is my
dick inside you
let's key is my I'm asking you if my
penis is inside is inside of you in any
of the in any of the holes that you have
I know oh cool
then don't tell me what to do with my
body